I first met our speaker and his lovely
wife penny when I graduated from
Hillsdale College and went out to
Claremont to study for my PhD in
political science at the time he was
president of the Claremont Institute a
position he held for fifteen years
before coming to Hillsdale what we
graduate students quickly learned about
him is the same thing Hillsdale students
today learn about him at heart he's a
teacher he's always teaching something
else we learned about him is that like
all good teachers if you claim to know
something in his presence it makes you
something of a ripe target the goal of
education is after all the discovery of
truth sometimes students get that wrong
and it has to be pointed out that
happens to me at least quite frequently
well I urge you to visit the Hillsdale
campus and sit in on one of his classes
or go with him to the Student Union and
have lunch with him and some Hillsdale
students and what you'll see is he
hasn't changed a bit
at Hillsdale he teaches courses on
various topics including the
Constitution Aristotle CS Lewis and
others he's the author of several books
including the best-selling Churchill's
trial Winston Churchill and the
salvation of free government it's been
my privilege and honor to work with him
at Hillsdale for almost 20 years now his
topic today is politics and education
would you please welcome back to the
podium the 12th president of Hillsdale
College Larry P R
[Applause]
thank you thank you all for being here
by the way wasn't that wild yeah did you
understand what he said he did in the
beginning of his speech we have asked
him here to Hillsdale College to present
you to him to you our guest and we're
kind of a big deal
and his first step was to audit us great
yeah okay be careful don't ask him over
to your house it's hilarious all right
we for years we don't need more because
now we have our own lawyer which cost
more money but we used to keep a lawyer
in Washington and the job was to keep
them to keep the federal government from
giving us any money because they do you
know they would in a heartbeat
okay so welcome I'm looking for the
Provost but I don't see him okay I'm
gonna give a great man in honorary
degree some time this morning and when
he shows up I'm just gonna give it to
him and you'll like the story okay so
[Music]
last night I said that we're
schizophrenia at the college because so
much is going right and so much
threatens to go wrong and I'm gonna
explain why I think that is what's going
on in the world that makes all this I'll
start with a quote from Churchill
because you know he was a very great man
in the may of 1938 you know think what
was going on in the world in May of 1938
in October the mute the Munich Agreement
was made in March of 39 Hitler took the
rest of Czechoslovakia just having
signed an agreement not to do it in
September of 1939 the big war started
and the speech
what are you doing here excuse us we
will be back to you eventually
okay so there is a man he started a
company the friendly ice cream company
in 1931 with his brother Curtis he lives
in Connecticut where he lives is like
everything about him he's a builder the
most important thing he's done in his
life is married his wife Helen who is
herself a chemistry teacher and a highly
educated woman and trustee of many
nonprofits and I can tell you sharpest
attack and together in Somers
Connecticut they have one hundred and
some acres and they've turned it into a
paradise of woods and trails and lakes
and he's always building more lakes he
likes Lakes the ones he's got he's
always digging them deeper and there's
seven wonderful structures on this and
the greatest of them is an exact replica
of Monticello made from bricks dug in
the same place Thomas Jefferson got his
a great act of love for no other reason
then it would be a great thing to do and
he wanted to celebrate his hundredth
birthday
well he's celebrating his 105th birthday
by giving all that to Hillsdale College
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
hey I'm pleased to report that neither
one of them heard what I just said so I
said I am wearing his wedding band and
his recent weakness he became fearful
and he wanted to make sure that his
wedding band didn't end up in the grave
so he worked for two days to get it off
behind my back and now I am wearing it
because he wants his ring and my ring
that he gave me are always going to be
together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now before I give them what I'm going to
give them with use all witnesses Helen
Blake is going to say a few words you
can come up here if you want to where
yeah this is a great day for us this is
a great honor and we are extremely
appreciative more so than any other
honor we have yet received because we
feel that this is the most important
thing that we've ever done so I'll tell
you what the what is and what the why is
the what is oh and by the way years and
years ago at the ceremony where I
received a master's degree the speaker
was who was that funny guy
oh gosh it'll come to me later on I let
you know but anyway he's a great speaker
afterwards he took a whole bunch of us
over to the noon editorial that he had
just donated to Springfield College in
Springfield Massachusetts and he said
here ladies and gentlemen is the price
of a doctorate at Springfield College so
so here is the what that is the price of
a doctorate at Hillsdale we have a
property in in Somers Connecticut which
is 77 acres in Connecticut and then
another 10 just over the line in
Massachusetts it's a beautiful property
pres created it out of a field and some
trees and there's a granite house at the
the highest part on the property and
there are eight ponds and there are
trails criss-crossing there's a
beautiful pool not anywhere right near
the house because pres thought that
would spoil the whole atmosphere of the
place so it's a pastoral setting and
every year he had to turn the Sun or
build something sometimes it was a
little building he loves architecture
and sometimes it was an engineering
project to get the water running on the
right places down to the bottom of the
hill and then when he was 98 years old
this the estate just north of us became
available and he decided that if he
could get it for a price that was
reasonable enough he would like to build
he
last project well I'd heard that a
million times but anyway my mouth
dropped open when he said what it was he
wanted to build and a replica of Thomas
Jefferson's Monticello he said I won't
do it unless you're all on board well I
had never said no to him yet and then he
said and how much are you willing to
lose well we built it in a record 14
months he had the guys our guys out
there
building a new trail going into the back
of the Monticello property or what was
going to be a Monticello and they were
working on the on the site before we
ever owned the property so anyway it's
built and it is gorgeous and when Larry
iron came to look at our property and we
took him over to take a look at
Monticello I could see the wheels
turning in his head
well I and pres thought a long time
about what we wanted to happen to our
property because all these years we've
shared it with our neighbors we have
kids fishing in our ponds the kids ice
skate play hockey on those ponds in the
wintertime we have people riding their
horses through our neighbors walk their
dogs on the trails so we wanted to be
able to preserve it we were afraid that
no matter what once we lost control of
it they'd come in and somebody would
come in and build a development so that
was one thing the next thing was we
really wanted it to do something good
and so one of my pet projects as in
recent years has been learning from the
original documents because as you know
our education system hasn't been doing
too well about preserving our values and
higher education isn't exactly high
anymore it's hard to consider it high
when the big issue is which bathroom to
use
so or if you have to have safe spaces to
protect you from ideas that don't sync
with your own so we thought maybe we
could do something to make the property
usable for retreats seminars are our
daughter and son-in-law over here also
have put their property in and they have
a beautiful house they're both artists
and there's a big art studio over the
garage that'd be perfect place for
seminars but anyway that was Susan's
idea that's my daughter that we look
into Hillsdale and so we did and realize
that because they don't take any
government money and because Larry
honors their leader hadn't because they
have stuck with their principles over
all these years we had the best chance
of preserving what we wanted to be our
legacy if we turned it all over to
Hillsdale and so that's the what and the
why
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so let's step out here we not not not
you yet wankum ever I want you to meet
this guy because he he takes care wadn't
Dumas and he takes care of the of the of
the Blake's and he's inspiring man and
he was for many years the head of the
prison guards at a big prison near
Somers Connecticut and so I'm hoping
although I haven't persuaded him yet
that he's eventually going to be our
Dean of men hi it's a high-security
prison Helen just told me she was
disappointed that you stood up to
applaud when he did because she was
about to say something great about me
and now y'all you'll never know what it
is I just have one little story about
this I you know we don't and we didn't
know these people and they called up and
it was just awesome you know right from
the start
and I go over there and we finally given
John Sweeney talks to of and he comes up
and tells me about this and you know we
only have know what to make of it and so
we go over to Connecticut and do course
and we meet them and he is 105 right now
and he's he's ailing a little bit but
what he was like and will be again like
is full of life and interest and he just
bubbles over right and so he built that
in Monticello and then he sold it to a
guy because he wanted the pleasure of
building in it for her to be there and
he'd taken it it's running right down
from his house their house and I and so
we go in and we look at that thing you
know it's just really great and I see
that the guy has got wedding pictures up
from his daughter getting married there
and I said you know I'm never gonna get
a hold of this house which I had already
formed the intention to do
and we go out and we go outside and
Prince said well did you like that and I
said like it I want it the next day he
bought it back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's there's a thousand reasons why
it's right to do this here today and
what I'm is you're all going to be
invited to seminars in Monticello and
it'll knock yourself act that the City
Council of my up Somers Connecticut is
not as enthusiastic as they might be
about us and and I think all that's
gonna be okay because there is some
semblance of the rule of law remaining
in America and and we're stubborn and
we'll keep at it and also will be really
great neighbors for them it's a
beautiful little town and they they want
the property kept as it is and I just
ask you you know we had our board
meeting on Wednesday and as we do every
time we began with the reading from the
1844 articles of association its the
contract with the state of Michigan that
gives rise to Hillsdale College we can't
change it on our own it's the law we
keep the law if we keep that law then
that makes us most likely to be able to
keep this law and we will keep it and we
thank you
[Applause]
I can't find the words I'm supposed to
say but I have memorized I think because
I've said it many times on behalf of the
faculty and Board of Trustees know on
behalf of the faculty of Hillsdale
College and with the authority of its
Board of Trustees I confer on press and
Helen Blanc the title doctors of public
service
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the bald guy is one of our greatest
professors and the provost of the
college at chemistry professor
Christopher Norman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a lot better than hearing me
blather on my name so I'm gonna make a
few points really fast and then you can
ask questions or say something if you
want to or else we'll have lunch I was
going to quote at length Winston
Churchill about what's going on in the
world because he is the greatest
statesman to live in our time the time
of the vast power of science and its use
to try to manage Saye societies
scientifically it's a new kind of thing
and I'll explain to you what it is but
it's dangerous it is the danger and it's
been growing for a hundred years all
over the world it's not hard to
recognize it it starts with a simple
idea and by the way what Adam said was
such great force and eloquence and I
meant what I said that guy is crazy yeah
that stuff is born in two things that
are in what I'm gonna what I want to
illustrate is a difference of temper and
outlook something fundamental has
changed in the way we think especially
the way people who govern people who are
in authority people who are lead think
and and the two things are they feel
entitled by a different qualification
than our consent to rule they they don't
they think that they know they think
that they have training and expertise
and then the second thing is a byproduct
and that is once you start trying to run
everything the way we run it now it gets
terribly complicated and that is just a
petri dish for graft and and the sense
of entitlement that's behind it is the
reason it can run rampant and and by the
way your reaction to his speech into the
the effectiveness of his organization
they are a testament to the fact that
the battle is not over yet here's what
you have to see where science comes from
the Latin word to know knowing is the
highest human activity Aristotle's
metaphysics which you know it's a
difficult book I confess it but it's
very inspiring book you should read it
the first line is the human soul
stretches itself out to know it's the
reason schools work it you know if you
just know what to do right started on
the assumption they want to know and
start on the assumption that they want
to know things of lasting importance and
all of a sudden you then realize the
learning is in them and so the age of
science that's a Latin word that's the
age where knowing is a big thing and it
doesn't just mean the Natural Sciences
although beholding the world one of
crispy Norman's colleagues a physicist
Ken Hayes gave a inspiring convocation
talk and I mean it a you can see it on
our website if you have trouble find it
I'll send you a link and he did this
PowerPoint and it these incredibly
dramatic photographs and it it navigated
between big physics gravitational
physics the movements of planets that
all that and teeny little Phenix physics
quantum mechanics and at one point he
shows us a photograph because you know
the Milky Way is very beautiful and it
you can see very fine pictures of it but
now we have pictures of what's on the
other side of it it's but it's better
and you just see that and ken Hayes it's
a it just shows his soul is in good
order he put that up there and everybody
at the convocation you know 1500 of us
or so we just all stop and stare at that
you know and he does and he's a
sophisticated you know very experienced
physicist he sees the beauty of that
thing and just to see that thing is
worthwhile it's an end not a means and
also the experience of seeing it
elevates one that's what science is
what's supposed to be now technology is
a very different set of words logos as
reasons what we can do in the beginning
was the word that word for word and John
1:1 is logos Tecna is art or making can
you see making and knowing or different
things making is very valuable but it
can never be anything except inferior to
the thing that it makes somebody made
the chair
the chair is very useful they wouldn't
have undertaken the activity of making
the chair except they want the chair the
chair calls the activity into being and
you can just see there's just a chain of
being goes right up and making is at the
bottom of the chain it has to be there's
just logical accept now what we think is
technology is the most important thing
making and we don't look anymore
as much at least at the things to behold
the things to know the reason to make a
telescope is you can see seeing is good
so that reversal is just a little thing
and yet its liberated vast movements the
people who invented the new kind of
government in America it was actually
invented by more older and more
fundamental thinkers especially in
Germany in the early 19th century in
America it comes in the late 19th
century they said look at all this
progress of science they don't mean
science beholding they mean technology
and if we see all this progress
we could we could use it to perfect the
society we can have more power we can
arrange things more systematically now
already there's a problem that they
didn't stop and think about if you just
want in our Constitution reader
representative and fundamentally
important papers and speeches by many of
these people Woodrow Wilson and Herbert
Crowley Frank good now John Dewey you'll
see you'll find in there the what's not
in the speeches is what's all over for
example Plato and Aristotle yeah we have
power we humans the hard question is how
should we use it or to put it in the
Socratic term what is the good that's
not their question they never asked that
question they ask instead how can we use
more power and the ability to do that
becomes a title to rule if you're the
one who knows the scientific way to
organize the society you can rule in the
name of that and that's not the same as
ruling by consent of the governed and so
then some practical changes start coming
and they start coming in a hurry and
they follow inevitably and they're just
radically different from the way before
one of the reasons that you know very
principled people in good good principle
in politics don't see the right thing to
do is because they don't really know
anything except this this way of
governing we have now that has prevailed
for seventy years 60 years and that's
two generations that means nobody's seen
it right you would have to read books
and unusual activity
scientific planners in this new way gain
authority power ships from elected
officials to tenured professionals you
know I believe Adam didn't deny it
but but there's an implication you could
draw from what he said that we have to
control Congress I don't think so I
think we have to make it accountable
again that means it should make the laws
and we should fire them if we don't like
the laws they make because the laws are
now made by people too who are simply
unaccountable it's a shocking fact that
last year the Congress passed about the
same number of laws it did in 1850 and
every year since then about 100 to 150 a
year but the number of laws is a great
multiple of that you know the last year
of Obama they added 80,000 pages to the
Federal Register a record fewer since
he's gone but that where did those laws
come from the answer is kind of hard to
say because there are a hundred and
fifty rulemaking agencies in the federal
government and it's not possible for any
elected official by himself to govern
what they do and the Congress divided
almost always effectively they cannot
all that's in the name of expertise we
need expert agencies for transportation
for airports for schools for everything
right and they make rules they have
rulemaking processes and they make them
by this by that not not by the score
they make them by the tens of thousands
all the time
another thing changes these agencies and
all of this by the way is because we
want more expertise in the government
see I'll quote one Winston Churchill I
got a bunch of but I'm not gonna say him
but I'll quote this one Churchill says
and one of the most important things he
ever said is little-noticed he said in
this house he's talking about the House
of Commons his beloved place there is no
room for expertise we rule by common
sense English what British were these
representative of a people with common
sense and that means if the thing cannot
be reduced to common sense
and it has to be district you know like
nuclear bombs right
although van orman could probably build
a nuclear bomb the rest of us can't he
then if he's doing that has to report
directly to someone elected because
that's a very great power and the whole
question about politics is you have to
have government how do you control it
right you have to empower it you have to
you also have to control it and consent
of the governed is the key tool and that
I'm saying is what's breaking down here
now these agencies because they're
expert agencies over their purview and
and it's significant see that they each
have a discreet purview but there's
enough of them that they have purview
over everything and they Eve's because
they're experts they'd only make the
regulations the legislative power they
enforce the regulations
that's the executive power if one of
them finds you or penalizes you you can
sue them you have to sue them in front
of a judge that works for them
right in 1979 78 some time in our
history we the Department the Department
of Health Education and Welfare it was
you know named us out by name and said
that if our students who are going to
have the student loans which they don't
have anymore it's the only federal money
we ever took but we took the view that
that was aid to the students and then
when they brought us a letter we
wouldn't answer it you know who the
devil are they and you know if they
don't like what the students are doing
with the money well they got a contract
with students that's what we thought
right and so they decided in Carter
Administration they decided no you have
to do everything we say right there was
public threats that they would close
down any college and and it didn't do it
right so eventually we sued them and we
sued them in Denver Colorado why the
Department of Education Health Education
and Welfare was in Washington DC
we're in Hillsdale Michigan so they said
they moved the whole thing out to Denver
just to cost us more money and we had to
sue in front of a judge that worked for
them and then in a miraculous
development we won and of course they
then immediately sued us in federal
court so you got to do it all over again
right legislative executive and judicial
what what is what is the what gives the
Constitution of the United States its
structure what do the clauses say
Congress let executive judicial states
ratification process amendment process
final transition there's seven and each
one's about some necessary function
divided by the levels in parts and
branches of government that just gets
collapsed now that's the first
consequence right now these people are
very powerful in their purview dang near
all power
very hard to stop them very hard to stop
them if you're the President of the
United States or anybody the second
consequence they make so many laws now
and just remember what I said the
Congress is actually incapable of making
so many laws when Adams said about the
productivity of Congress that they only
meet first 800 days or whatever he said
my immediate hours 800 hours my
immediate reaction is just good cut it
in half but but these agencies are just
you know they're just running and they
make and that that's why it becomes
possible for everything to be regulated
the way it is in schools right there's a
federal curriculum down to the unit plan
right now not enforceable directly
through many states that that that can
see the bureaucratic system they're 23
million people working for the
government the United States about 21
million in state and local and about two
and a half million or something in
federal I bet Adam knows all these
numbers and but but and that used to be
you know most government was local
except now it's part of a unified
top-down system where money and
authority passed back and forth
Authority mostly down and so you've got
this unified system you know I I have
the vice of motorcycle-riding and I
wrote an article to 25 years ago in
national because if you ride motorcycles
I mean it's really stupid but but it's
also cool and you know and and I grew up
in a little town and I never noticed it
before but when you go through and the
back roads you know through a little
town there's almost always a building
that looks different than the other
buildings and I began to notice it and
then I began to think about my little
town
and the thing that used to be one of the
banks had become a federal agency it's
called the Black River Area Development
Corporation I don't know what that thing
does I never have it's been there since
I was a boy but the time I went off to
college
see that's right so you know I went to
college in 72 all that it started to
grow in 65 and on after that and then
now there's now they took over the old
hospital are huge and what does it
really do there's a federal agency in
every town and there wasn't for what
1789 to 170 years there was none and
then there was all of a sudden and now
they're everywhere
a guy fixed my motorcycle in Billings
Montana and I'd passed by the big
federal building there and I said his
name is Gunnar McCombs you go to the
building's Yamaha shop you can meet him
he's a great man and he saved my bacon
our motorcycles had broken down and we
were in Montana and finally got this guy
on the phone and he said I gotta get out
there he said it's getting close to dark
and I said is that bad and he said well
you're on the Crow Reservation and it's
dangerous after night so I get back to
my buddy Bruce Sanborn a trustee of the
college and he said what he said I said
I said we're ten miles from the Little
Bighorn and we have an Indian problem
[Laughter]
he came and saved us but then he worked
on my motorcycle all day the next day
and I stood around and talked to him and
I said what's what happens over there
and he said ah nobody knows what happens
over there but I'm glad it's there and I
said why are you glad it's there and he
said he said my treat
I'm going to be rich working six hours
six days a week 14 hours a day in my
motorcycle business I'm going to be rich
and I'm gonna be rich in exactly eight
years I saw him in ten years and I said
Gunther are you rich and he said I am
you know he had his inventory
he knew how long it took him to pay it
off you know and anyway he's an awesome
guy and he said but my one indulgences
he says every two years I buy a new
truck and I shop for them over in that
parking lot and I said why did you do
that and he said because they've got all
the best trucks over there those federal
employees right so that's and just
remember that's a force right it's
important and it's grown now the system
that I'm describing that system prevails
in roughly this form from Beijing to
Washington to Paris to Moscow right it's
the global phenomenon and once it
started it's never been stopped now in
America it's very hard to stop it
because the system consumes you know if
you count the regulatory cost about 52
or 3% of the economy that means half the
money we encounter is connected to that
touched by that influenced by that and
that changes the constitutional
proportions in a very serious way
because you know I you probably see me
do this I do it all the time but there's
a imagine America's a big ol circle and
everything in it's everything in America
is inside the circle and then imagine a
little circle that's 10% of the whole
and that's the government because that's
about the historic percentage of the
government to the rest of the economy
and then there's this unique thing
Madison says this and the 63rd
federalism he says this is the most
important thing about the Constitution
and the key innovation if you want to
understand the Constitution start with
this almost nobody knows this
- except you take our online courses so
all of the sovereign power is located
out in the big circle and that's never
happened before no class of lords and
ladies
no tycoons no hereditary monarchs no
warrior class with political power just
all of us we're sovereign we have
legitimate power to rule that's the
first step but the second step is
equally important we delegate all of our
power to rule we don't do anything
directly ourselves except elections we
delegate all our power to rule to the
little circle and that means between
elections we can't do anything which
teaches us to think before we act and it
means that the people who can do things
all the time are entirely beholden to us
that's the first step in the structure
of the Constitution United States and
the decisive and also according to James
Madison unique step America's
contribution to constitutional
government the greatest it actually
achieves what Aristotle is after which
was a mixed regime that is to say take
all the Warriors and all the rich people
and all the well-born and take the mini
and sort of get power from all of them
and mix them all up that'll be more
stable he thought well all the power
comes from us but it's delegated in
different ways and at different times
into that little circle that's America
right and it's the reason you know the
principles of America are extremely
important but in the way that a final
cause the ultimate purpose of anything
is extremely important to understanding
it but to how it works
the form the look of it right that's
what that is right now all you got to do
to see what this change means is if you
just take that big circle and then take
the little circle and make it more than
half the hole now all of a sudden the
little circle is very powerful so it's
not that little anymore and there's some
common interest among them right because
although these agencies are separate
from one another they represent the same
kind of thing and they get their power
from that thing and their station from
that thing and their money from that
thing and so there's our constitutional
crisis and as I say and I want you to
know when Winston Churchill was eight
was 24 years old in 1898 he wrote his
first thing about this 18 26 years old
he said you are 24 years old sir sorry
he wrote his first thing about this and
he never stopped writing about it he
understood it he understood that the
same awesome power in human hand hands
that makes war potentially destructive
of everything also makes administration
potentially destructive of everything
that's why it's so hard to hold it to
account it's why you have to be a kind
of a genius wild man to do it you know
thank God for him but he's a nut and I
salute you I'm a nut too now now you
know first of all these things in the
calculus of nature and the in the way
things work
it follows there is a tremendous danger
right now this has all come to such a
head and it just goes with it
inseparably there's a tremendous
opportunity to because you know people
don't like this they never have no it
goes can't be stopped it seems
but where is it popular where does
anybody
where does bureaucratic government enjoy
wide public support anywhere where is
that ever never in America it's the
reason left and right people are kind of
interested in what he has to say and
many of them supported even on the left
you know they're the ones who are eating
out of that specific rice rice bowl
Matthew told me earlier they're the ones
that won't go along right but most
people are not like that and so I think
this I think you know first of all have
you noticed I mean you know it's a
everything's up in the air right now
right the political coalition's are
shifting we don't know how far they'll
shift or if they'll continue to shift or
they'll stay shifted but we do know that
the Republican president sitting now is
weaker in the suburbs and stronger in
the inner city then Republicans
typically are we know that the governor
of the state was elected by 45,000 votes
and we know that the exit polls say now
they're not perfectly rebuttal reliable
but they indicate something say that he
got 60,000 more votes from black women
than any Republican has recorded to have
received and he got him by going to
charter and and and voucher schools and
saying what's just a simple fact they're
going to take away your school and they
did that in the inner-city think of this
you know how many how many of us have
engaged in talk of the dependent class
you know because there is a kind of long
term dependent class in America well
some have made the terrible mistake and
I am glad that I have never referred to
the 47% who won't vote for us because
they're on the dole somebody said that
one time
not good
those people are going back to work
right turns out they're human they would
rather live of their own right they you
know we've got some in our charter
schools I think in the latest numbers 43
percent of our charter schools our
members of racial minorities and you
know they if you include the girls in
the schools they're all that 90 percent
of them are part of the overall 90
percent minority of America it's but you
know what when we first started doing
this you know and you can you know
they're easier to do in the suburbs
usually but somebody said well you know
there's no parent structure in the inner
city and I said there's got to be
something and they said why and I said
because if there's a five-year-old alive
somebody loves that kid just go find
that person right that's happening I
think there's something you know I pray
for that right I'd give up votes in the
suburbs to get that why it unites the
country and it gives everybody a chance
to what do what they want which is to
live a fully human life raise your kids
be responsible I think that I went and
talked to the vice president the other
so I know him not in a long time and I
got all fired up and lectured him and
he knows his specific greatness is he
humours me lord knows what he says when
I leave but I said just remember you
know who's the proper sovereign of
Education sovereignty is properly
located in the school the school what's
in the school the children and the
parents and the teachers a community of
love right I can just tell you I'm a
teacher right it's a pain in the butt
it's just the most wonderful thing you
know and like the greatest teacher in
America I wish my daughter were here
I've there's a woman in Leander Texas
and I've turned her into a tourist
attraction
she's the kindergarten teacher at the
Leander Classical Academy mrs. Reardon
and you know I've published about her
she's very proud although she Creed you
know checks to my grammar and and this
woman you know it's just their little
wigglers given a kindergarten class i
mean it's hopeless when my kids are that
age I turned to my wife one time and I
said this is like having dinner with a
bucket of snakes and she gets them to
learn and it's magical and they're
exhausted at the end of the day because
they have given their all because it's
the greatest thing they can do you see
and mrs. Reardon she can do that and you
can't put on a form how to do that see
she doesn't need any help we help her
right how do we help her well you know
we got a bunch of fancy-pants knowledge
and we're teachers so you know if you
want to know something about physics or
you want to know something about
literature something about history
we got people who really know that and
the teachers would love to hear from
those people we don't try to teach the
students they can do it better than we
can and we mostly learn from them
the best ways to reach the students of
their age groups because they do it and
they're humans and they can do it
instead of love you see and that means
it follows as a simple deduction we have
to keep our hope about this no matter
how this election goes right
sooner or later or as Churchill used to
say sooner or later and sooner and later
it's just a fact
people love to learn and they love to
have their lives in their own hands and
they love their children and they should
have control of those things and so what
I said to the veep was I said you should
should go try to get the teachers to
vote for you and the parents because
they're living beneath the bureaucracy
it's a scandal that more than half the
employees of the public schools are not
teachers in our charter schools the
ratio is 8 to 1 or 6 to 1 at the worst
in favor of the teachers and what are
those others do first of all they eat up
way more than half the money and second
they tell the teachers what to do the
verb they use for teaching now is
delivery and what they try to teach in
education schools by the way which have
power of law behind them because in many
states you need a certification from
them to teach in a public school I am
not qualified to teach the Constitution
or Winston Churchill or Aristotle in the
Michigan public schools
I'm proud right because what do you have
to do you have to learn methods that
they prescribe from the top down and you
may say reaching all the way up to the
Secretary of Education that's not where
it reaches up to it reaches up to the
elevated halls of Harvard in such places
see and and you know the research duong
university is the strongest single force
in america today because it controls so
much of everything
he did those studies right there is
Roland doe but power is more important
you know Machiavelli said money goes to
power not the other way around that
money goes there because those people
are strong to expose them it's a way of
making them weaker so I'll just
concluded we have the privilege of
living in a moment of great turning for
good or ill I don't agree with one thing
the speaker said last night the truth of
this is not going to be found in the
middle Lincoln says he was always pushed
to find a compromise and I will tell you
he and Winston Churchill would
compromise almost anything to avoid war
because they knew its horrors but he
said a man who is half slave and half
free is not it's like a man who's
neither a living nor dead man and you're
not likely to run across it X and not X
cannot be compromised either all men are
created equal and endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
that to secure these rights governments
are instituted among men deriving their
just powers from the consent of the
governed that's what the fights about
right now it's a fight for everything
and so I end with my eternal Action Plan
learn and teach others and that will
save the world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]